[Music]
okay everybody this is my spoiler review
of Orphan first kill this is the prequel
to The Original orphan film from 2009
which actually came out 13 years ago so
I'm gonna age myself here but I was 17
when that film came out I remember
seeing in theaters and loving it I'd
actually re-watched it just recently to
prepare for this review and I loved it
even more as an adult I absolutely just
am amazed by that film and also that
character of Esther or we could say Lena
but I love Isabelle Fuhrman I think
she's a great actress so I was really
excited for this film but it was really
also special about that original film is
Vera Farmiga you can't go wrong with her
she's a horror Legend but I was kind of
holding my expectations a little in
place for this film own because when I
saw I was a different director and a
different writer you have to kind of
just look at it with a clean slate now
and just take in see what they do and
what is so interesting about this film
is that it's coming out so long after
the original so you're kind of like
why'd it take so long to come out the
other one from a successful film like
orphan but this film
I was really enjoying the beginning like
the first half of this film the first 40
minutes I was invested I thought it was
pretty good for what it was being a
prequel I love everything they did in
the psychiatric hospital with Lena I
like that they use a black light opening
Graphics here alluding to again how she
does her paintings but I like to see
that all the patients in the psychiatric
hospital were under her fingertips like
the Lena we knew from the original
orphan film how she used the kids in
that house the same way and that's uses
this piece of candy to have one of the
patients help her get out I like the
kill in the back of the trunk she did to
the doctor and then we get to see her
play some piano here which she's known
for which is great and there's a lot of
good stuff here we got to see her
looking for the Esther that was the
missing identity she was gonna use that
missing childhood that was really
fascinating we got to see the origin of
her Bible her finding the alpha to match
that child and I like that we got to see
her covering her wounds and they even
show showed her right away painting but
also having her tantrum like on the
airplane and we got to see the origin of
the Glory of Love which she sung in the
original film and that that was playing
on the record player in this house when
she's reunited with Esther's real family
and we see that Esther was missing for
four years the actual Esther and that
she's taking the place so first you're
kind of wondering how the original
mother doesn't recognize it's not her
own daughter but then maybe you kind of
accused it as like she wants it to be so
that's kind of her being in denial but
we will get a Twist that we're gonna get
to that explains more of this but what I
really liked about the beginning of this
film is that I like that we got to see a
perspective from Esther's point of view
through this film where the original
film it was really a lot through the
mother played by Vera for Miga so you
can't do another twist like the original
because we know now who Esther really is
that she's this Lena she's this older
woman but it was interesting to kind of
see everything now in the suspense of of
her getting caught right we're seeing
what happened with that family and we
knew the house would burn down here and
maybe my complaints towards the
beginning the only problems I was really
having was it was falling a lot of
pre-qualitis where a lot of story beats
were too similar like the way she first
see her really jealous of the husband
and the wife is the same exact way his
original film just looking at them while
they're in the bedroom also having a
very similar bullying older brother with
bullying friends so at that point in the
film I also felt like it was just what a
lot of prequels do or sequels even they
just take a more successful film and hit
a lot of the same story beats so to me
it felt like they were trying to
counteract that by having this totally
unexpected twist but this is where I was
ready to accept some of those
pre-qualitis things I was just talking
about and see this movie as a pretty
solid film and the way it was going and
I thought this Choice completely ruined
this movie for me I thought this was one
of the silliest twists I have ever seen
and it was one of those types of twist I
would have walked out of the theater if
I saw us in theaters and wasn't
reviewing it I ended up watching the
whole film but my eyes rolled back so
far here I'm gonna explain why I hated
this twist before we though even get
into that twist I also was annoyed that
this detectively didn't know much about
we did know that he was suspicious of
Esther I wanted to see why he had such a
hunch on why this wasn't the real Esther
they never showed that like they showed
that he had found the fingerprints to
catch her but we never knew why he was
taking photos of her in the beginning
why was he all of a sudden from the
start on to Esther that was never
explained which I did not like now where
the inconsistencies lie in this twist
which I thought was just ridiculous was
we see the twist explain if some reason
I've watched the film and you watch a
spoiler review that the real Esther died
by the hands of Gunner which was first
seemed like an accident that happened
and they were covering but the way he
says I'll kill you like I did the real
Esther to her later on makes me think it
wasn't an accident which is kind of
crazy so you kind of see how evil this
mom and her son are and that they didn't
tell the husband that they know what
really happened to his real daughter so
she offers Lena to play the role to keep
the husband happy or she's like I'll
send you off to prison you're going to
be screwed either way so you're under my
control all right well it's crazy first
off to that she knew from the start this
wasn't her daughter and she was just
doing this to keep her husband happy
because she liked how happy he looked
having the daughter there again who's
not really the daughter but what doesn't
make sense about this is that if that's
her motivation to keep Esther there it
goes back and forth because she found
the pics of her husband in Esther's
Bible like the original film and this
didn't set her off but fine with enough
to keep her there but then she flips out
about it later when she sees her hitting
on her husband when they're painting and
what doesn't make sense about the timing
of this is that she also tried poisoning
her because we saw the food kill the
mouse but the poisoning attempt started
before she saw her with the painting so
was she already planning to kill her
from what happened when she found in the
Bible but we know she didn't because she
made an agreement with her so then why
did she poison her before that incident
with the painting it's a lot of like
wait which is it your characters
constantly not explained while changing
her mind and the problem with this twist
is then you realize that you have all
your characters being hateable and
villainous so you have no one to root
for and that you're in this moment where
everyone knows what's going on except
this husband who is just oblivious to
everything which was a problem with the
original film if there's some critique I
have that is that how oblivious husband
is they just double down on making the
husband even stupider and then you're
just now watching these hateable
villainous characters fighting with each
other where in the original film you
were still rooting for the character
played by Vera Farmiga and that was
built up from the start that you would
get that payoff by the end against
Esther the villain Esther is already
developed by this film a really amazing
villain from the past so Let Her Shine
and be that villain you're up you're up
staging her by having Julia's Styles be
this Mastermind now which was ridiculous
and having her also coaching her for a
little bit was weird and it kind of
downplayed kind of to me the Brilliance
of the character of Esther so a lot of
it was shaking my head and made me feel
like this seemed like a case where the
writers were just trying to freshen
things up too much where it was like way
the other way where it was like no this
is like you don't need to have another
villain in a story where you already
have a great villain in Esther where it
then feels like an Alien vs Predator
Freddie versus Jason type of movie now
you're just hating everyone and you
completely start losing grasp on tension
and suspense and also there's moments
where the tone was lost of just this
franchise of Orphan where that's where I
really lost faith in these creators when
Esther is just driving and they're
playing maniac and puts her shades on
come on that's that's the type of stuff
that's so easy to think of and so silly
and out of the lane of the creepiness
that should be the orphan franchise and
where that cringing writing is happening
with Julia Stiles character which was
the worst character of this movie and
ruined this movie for me was
she's now decided that she's gonna fake
a suicide of Esther and she's like your
suicide will break daddy's heart but he
will get over it so again just going
against her whole character's motivation
so it's constantly flip-flopping and
doesn't make much sense at all which
really is frustrating and also the movie
did a good job at the beginning right
where they have to trick us that the
actress of Isabelle Fuhrman remember she
was a kid in the original film so now
she is I think 25 she's an adult so
she's taller so whenever you're seeing
behind the character of Esther that it's
a child actor who's substituted and then
you see in the back of a header is a
child and then when it's close-ups it's
really the actress Isabelle Fuhrman and
they're probably putting her on you know
bigger chairs or that trick where they
put her in a bigger set than the other
actors to make her look smaller and
maybe even sometimes she's talking to
like the father when it's just a
close-up and her you might see his body
he might be a taller actor they're
putting in there so they're doing all
those tricks but it was working for me
and in the end they got sloppy and I
feel like even got sloppy with the
costume where there's that scene that
really stuck up me towards you when
she's talking to the husband and she's
still supposed to look like a little
girl to him and she has her hair down
she looks just like Isabelle Furman
today she looks like a 25 year old so I
was kind of like what why did they stop
being consistent with the costume before
looking in Disguise like a kid as she's
supposed to be out in public so I feel
like they really dropped the ball at
that as well and you just start it's
like your classic bad horror film tropes
like especially with the burning
building where Jill Scott has character
is still running after Esther when she
should really just get out of that house
when it's burning to the ground but no
she keeps going for her which was just
silly and where the writing really
suffers and you see again just at the
end moment it was cool to have a see it
come full circle where Esther's gonna go
now to the orphanage in the first film
but unfortunately I hated the second
half of this film it really disappointed
me and it really almost was the worst
thing a prequel could do or it ruined to
me the character of Esther and Lena if
you want to call her that I think
there's faith if they want to try to
make a better film and make a sequel I
think he still can I think you can kind
of justify her dying in the original
film and you know we saw her go into the
ice they could rewire that to do a
sequel I think a sequel might be the
best way to approach this because I
still think there's potential with this
great actor and character of Esther and
Isabelle Fuhrman but maybe just a
stronger story next time and just just
twist I it's one of those twists I want
to forget forever but I'm curious what
you guys think again I'm giving this a
4.6 let me know your thoughts on this
film did you like the twist did you like
what was happening the whole time what
were things that stood out to you I'd
love to hear your thoughts on this film
I read every commentary as much as I can
and please make sure to subscribe so you
don't miss one of my reviews of movies I
also do TV reviews as well and celebrity
interviews and please follow me at Steve
barley show on Twitter Instagram and
Tick Tock for more of me and I'll see
you next time